when you travel into unknown lands
to discover new parts of the globe
it is to ensure
the records of your discoveries
are delivered back
safe and sound
with or without you
[Music]
i'll need a volunteer to accompany me
across the ice cap to retrieve the
findings of the missing denmark
expedition
captain i'd like to come with you
if you'd allow me but what do you know
about sledging and surviving on the ice
when it's 40 below he's a mechanic
risking your life he's the only man
willing to make the trip the denmark
expedition all died who knows if they
even found anything
three
two
one
it's like we've landed on the moon
what do you
think really happened to the denmark
expedition
you never think you can't make it you
always believe there'll be a way
it's not working anymore there's no life
didn't even see a bird is there a point
where perhaps we want to give up we have
a map we will find it and we will be
back on the ship by august
[Music]
you don't think we can make it do you
there's truth in every dream
they say there's truth in every dream
you do know that no one is coming to get
you
you're going to die up here
do you believe in ghosts
you might freeze to death
starve
lose your mind
but we must push on
to hope
[Music]
[Music]
you